I go out for some drinks or if I get
you're in the past especially because
I'm a big drinker now like I'll have a
few drinks I'm not I could do that but
there were those times I always made bad
decisions always why'd I go home with
that girl why did I do that why did I
whatever that was and that always made
me go you know I don't wanna drink for a
while and that's I think what everybody
does is like oh we've made a bad
decision so let's stop for a while until
we get drunk again and make another
badge then I'll stop
so did you did you like stop four months
ago because of a bad decision No so four
months ago I was in the hospital so I
was hospitalized I drank the entire
summer by choice really heavily so I was
like you know what I'd pitch the TV show
in the spring they didn't get it
and I was like talking to my other
creator and I'm like I'll just pay for
this on my own I'll just pay for the
pilot and he was like okay and he kind
of flaked out a little bit and then I
was just really frustrated and I had
this summer off so I was like you know
what I'm just tired of the business I'm
tired of so much [ __ ] I'm just gonna get
drunk everyday I didn't have to film I
didn't have to do anything I had a
handful of shows and I was like I'm just
gonna drink no stand up yeah stand up
shows right and so I just did that I
just drank and then the curveball which
just happens with people that my
sister-in-law died pretty unexpectedly
and then another friend died and then
two friends committed suicide and that's
a real wrench you know what I mean which
is an understatement this will happen
all before or during what Brody Stephens
killed himself beginning of the year and
then my friend Mark killed himself and
that manifested even harder cuz when
Brody had taken his life I was sober and
filming and I it was awful but I didn't
really like drinking losing you know I
didn't turn to the bottle and then when
I drank over the summer with all that
death around me and then Brody Singh hit
again it was just an eye of the storm
you know and that's where you don't want
to go with if you're drinking or
drinking a lot you know sometimes it's
cathartic where you just want to numb
yourself
but there's a balance that you have to
find where you know then it gets
dangerous and I went to that territory
where I was drinking really heavy and
not a good mindset
well I remember just like I've never
seen on Facebook I remember seeing
Instagram Twitter like he's always funny
[ __ ] you're doing funny [ __ ] out there
wisecracks doing this everybody's
laughing James but then I see I noticed
it wasn't just one but there's like I'm
heartbroken blah blah if you or someone
you know suffering from this please get
help while blah I love you though but
there were a few there weren't like if
there was one then there was another
yeah I was like wow what the [ __ ]
wordy like you know he's got people
around and then he really loved and
admired dying and you mix alcohol with
that and stuff and now you're feeling
the when you say you were feeling down
was it just like [ __ ] it I don't want to
be here either
I want to be with them no it wasn't like
that it was just the kind of thing where
a what could I have done my friend Mark
who drank himself to death had been
battling it for a while and I tried to
help him through it and he would hit me
up and he's like hey man I can't stop
drinking and he goes I've dialed it down
I've scaled it back to beer I've done
this and I go you need you need a detox
mark he was living in Florida and I was
in LA and I go you need an assisted
detox you need to find somebody you know
because you should not it's really a
dice roll and I've done it before when
you go cold turkey like that it depends
on how much you drink but I mean me and
Mark [ __ ] drank for those of you
listening
I was drinking easily about a half of
vodka a day a fifth
yeah and that's easily and Mark was at
that level and it's you know if you
decide to like you need to take help her
break or whatever you you really need
somebody to monitor the whole turkey o
die you can go yeah you can die I've
been to detox before and they were like
alcohol and they said xanax were the two
worst come downs on the planet they said
those are really really shocking dear
sister know that one yeah so it's like
those are really intense anyway
you know it just it was just hard to say
new mark battled with it you know and it
was I got the text that he passed and I
just couldn't I just lost it and I you
know then I just drank and you know I I
don't know I was already on I was
already drinking so much you know I I
just couldn't I just decided to drink
through it whether you just start to
feel like you know [ __ ] I should have
spent more time with him I should have
talked him through it I should have done
that you always should have right yeah I
mean I did what I could there wasn't you
know I hit we and another friend and I'd
reached out to him because he lived by
him you know and you know we were just
heartbroken cuz we all had battled with
it you know and it was just it was just
really rough that one really like hit me